they do it on the second one yes yeah
he'll get the ball okay sets his feet
now he's just talking to Harrison Barnes
and then he then he regroups to shoot so
I guess it relaxes him so the Maverick
coach has found something in his motions
and they're doing something
psychologically to break whatever his
issue was in LA so far so good when you
shoot an 81 on your career 45 hey one of
the reasons I want to mention their
bunch of Puerto Rico the job that JJ
Barea has done since the hurricane that
helped it's got to be seen to be
believed
45 of the he's talking to Harrison
Barnes the lied and then he shoots the
free-throw that's his new moon
so Durant Dre Jordan at the free-throw
line and one of the revelations of the
season his free-throw shooting they're
remarkable it has done a complete 180
seats Dale Davis make 85 out of 100 in
the chute 100 free throws to private
make 85 it put 21,000 people and turn
the lights on sing the national anthem
maybe a 50 percent free throw well you
ready for this one I think you're so
right on this you know there's gonna be
a lot of talk about Dennis being a catch
and shoot guy because Luke will have the
ball more right but Dennis is so much
better with a shot when he gets that
little rhythm with a drum he just feels
it's sold out Aten has five we haven't
seen him in quite some time
Jackson has five a covo has five Holmes
has five
they're gonna have to bring dragon
bender out of mothballs here thanks
don't chase